Well. Good morning. Our topic for
this time and next is another,
the really ancient diseases in our course,
which is tuberculosis,
tuberculosis was present in ancient Egypt.
This is known from skeletons and from
mummies and it seems that tuberculosis has
been with human beings ever since.
They first began to gather
in substantial settlements,
which are essential for its transmission
and ways we'll be discussing.
It was present in ancient Greece and
in Rome and Hippocrates and Galen,
clearly new patients
suffering from tuberculosis.
It persisted in the Middle Ages,
so we're dealing not with the
new but a very ancient disease.
A question that you'll be asking is
whether indeed it's an epidemic disease,
would it perhaps be better
to describe it as endemic
and this again,
I think as when we dealt with malaria,
we see that some diseases are both endemic
and epidemic and I think the supplies
to tuberculosis as well.
One way of thinking of it might
be in terms of its timeframe.
If you look at any single generation,
it often seems that tuberculosis
isn't an epidemic disease.
It's present after all year after year.
It is contagious, but it's spread
slowly from person to person.
It's course in the
individual body of a patient.
It was often very slow and capricious.
It's clearly different from bubonic
plague from influenza or Asiatic cholera,
but if you take a longterm perspective,
it might seem that tuberculosis does
ebb and flow like an epidemic disease.
Perhaps one could think of it in terms
of an epidemic that lasts for centuries,
perhaps or decades in the case of the
body of a single patient and times.
In a sense,
one could say that tuberculosis could
be an epidemic disease in slow motion.
Our concern will be with Europe and North
America at a time of a vast upsurge,
and here I'm referring to Western Europe
that coincided with the industrial
revolution.
Here there are a number of factors that
lie in the background that contributed.
Probably one is a large skill pace of
indoor urbanization and we'll see the
impact of crowded housing
and poor ventilation,
which are decisive factors,
particularly in the case of a disease
that's a pulmonary disease above all the
rise of sweatshops and the factory
system again lead to crowding.
This time, not in the home, but in
the workplace and poor ventilation.
Now during the day as well as in the home
at night and thinking of low wages and
with that poor diet and a
compromised immune system.
Another factor that's very important
for diseases that are respiratory is
pollution of the atmosphere and the smog
in cities like London due to sit from
the burning of coal or particles due
to tobacco from smoking or again,
particles in mind,
shots or run hygienic workshops
all made their contribution.
In any case,
it's not by chance that England,
the first industrial nation experienced
an epidemic wave that crested between
the middle of the 18th century and the
middle of the 19th and then in the case
of England,
there was a slow,
steady decline from the later
decades of the 19th century.
And we can see this as well taking
place in countries that industrialized a
little bit later, say France,
Germany, Italy, Russia,
the upsurge began later,
but did so remorselessly
and then a decline set in.
But again, slightly later from
the beginning of the 20th century.
If you look at the geography
of tuberculosis in Europe,
it would also support this idea of a
clear relationship between tuberculosis as
a condition and the conditions
created by industrial development,
especially in it's traumatic early phases.
Tuberculosis was a major killer in
the northern industrial nations,
Britain,
Germany and France,
and it was less prevalent
and less industrial,
largely agricultural nations
such as Italy and Spain.
So there's this distinction to be made,
but also if you look at the
pattern of tuberculosis in Italy,
in Spain,
uh,
you would see not only was it less there,
but also it respected the distribution
of industrial development.
Take Italy for example,
we already talked in the case of malaria
about a major north south divide.
This is also true with
regard tuberculosis,
but in reverse tuberculosis and other
words was an affliction above all of
Italy's northern cities and it was much
less prevalent in the aquacultural south
where people worked out doors.
Well,
let's turn now to the nature of
the disease, how it's transmitted,
it's different forms and it's
symptomatology in the body.
The pathogen to begin with was first
discovered by someone we know well now and
a variety of contracts,
and this is Robert Kaul who discovered
it in 1882 the micro bacterium
tuberculosis,
which is
thought.
Now transmission tuberculosis can
be spread in more than one way,
but we're concerned and will be concerned
primarily with its dominant mode of
transmission, which is through
the air. In other words, uh,
suffer from tuberculosis,
we'll say cough,
sneeze,
spit,
okay.
And give off airborne droplets,
which are then inhaled by other people.
No,
a primary infection by most people who
come into contact with mycobacterium
tuberculosis, doesn't
develop, lead on to symptoms.
It usually heals,
but in those with
compromised immune systems,
the disease as the expression was,
is disseminated.
It can then lie dormant for years.
As I've said,
one of the things about
tuberculosis is it's enormous, uh,
capricious quality,
enormously capricious quality.
Alternatively,
it could produce disease within
weeks of the primary infection.
Mycobacterium tuberculosis can spread
via the bloodstream or the lymph system
too.
In fact,
a variety of organs and produce lesions
in virtually any tissue in the body.
I'll show you now a number of images
of suffers from tuberculosis in various
forms and I'm hoping that these images
won't be overly distressing to anyone.
Uh,
first this is squab Phila sometimes
called the king's eval which was here we
have [inaudible] of the neck are those
tuberculosis of the skin called Lupus.
Vulgarness.
Tuberculosis can also infect
them in NGS of the brain,
the bone and joints,
the kidneys,
the urinary and reproductive system and
can in fact the spine leading to severe
deformity and hunchback.
I'll show you the not form,
it's called pots disease and there's a
skeleton from a software of pots disease
or this would be what it would look like.
The disease can also affect the lining
of the abdominal cavity or the heart,
but overwhelmingly the most common form
of tuberculosis is of the lungs and this
is what we'll be dealing with primarily
in the course pulmonary disease,
also known as stasis or consumption.
We'll mention in passing that tuberculosis
is also a spread and was spread by
mill meat or milk of infected animals,
but that's a secondary tragedy within
the larger dominant pulmonary form of the
disease.
Now,
you know from your reading
response questions and from
Barnes is book this week
that tuberculosis is sometimes
referred to as a social disease.
And you'll see in your,
in trays that I've just sent you a,
um,
an email about social diseases
and how we might think of them.
But just for the moment,
you'll note that Barnes doesn't define
what he means by social disease by saying
that it was a social disease.
He's arguing that tuberculosis had a
predilection for certain social classes,
that it was a disease that was unlike,
um,
that it didn't affect all classes equally.
Now note that cholera for example,
um,
was a disease that didn't
affect all social classes.
Tuberculosis did in fact afflict
royal families, aristocrats,
artists' riders and professionals.
And this was an important factor in
the social response to the disease.
Given the mode of transmission
that is through the air,
it was inevitable that
that would be the case.
So even if we do decide to call
tuberculosis a social disease,
we need to make major qualifications,
but to focus on the rich and famous is
distorting because out of all proportion,
tuberculosis did.
And still a flicks the poor,
especially the urban poor.
Remember the risk factors we said living
in cities rather than the countryside.
Crowded unhygienic housing,
poor ventilation workplaces that were
similar to those of the home child labor
on mass lowered resistance due to
poor diet or preexisting diseases.
Tuberculosis then thrived in slums and
tenements among industrial workers and
among the inmates of alms
houses, prisons, barracks.
Let me give you some illustrations and
we'll look at some famous pictures.
I think that we have no better ones than
the photographs taken by Yaka Reese of
tenements and sweat shops in New
York City in the 1880s and nineties,
some of which were collected and is
really famous and influential book.
How the other half lives that was
published in 1890 and I'd like to show you
some of the pictures.
This is a slide of a tournament,
uh,
an ideal place for tuberculosis.
We'll be looking first at some pictures
of housing. And I'd like you just to,
you'd make the imaginative
leap of thinking what are
the kinds of conditions if
you live in these places that
facilitate the spread of tuberculosis.
Again,
this is from Yaka breeze,
a tenement in New York City.
Uh, here we see the conditions
in which people were sleeping.
This is what was called 7 cent lodgings
and an unhappy street pell street in New
York City. Um, and you can see, uh,
how tuberculosis would thrive
in conditions like this.
But let's also remember the tuberculosis
also thrive because of conditions at
work.
And here's a sweatshop in the garment
district in New York City again in the
1890s or here again,
another picture.
I think you get the point,
remember to that prison populations then
and now have been seriously affected
with consumption because the inmates
there have often lived in conditions like
those if tenements with ventilation or
lighting pervasive down overcrowding,
inadequate diet for sanitation
and conditions like that.
Tuberculosis runs riot.
Indeed,
The New York Times reported
in 1908 but it was a lie.
When judges sentenced
convicted felons to hard labor,
the truth,
the paper reported the sentence should
be labeled to hard labor and tuberculosis
and an inspection in 1905 the
New York state superintendent,
if prisons declared that sing
sing prison in particular,
and here I'm quoting from
the superintendent of
prisons if New York state,
he called it a hotbed for the culture
and spread of tuberculosis that should be
in band and as unfit for human habitation.
Well,
even if a person is infected,
as I said in the vast majority of people,
the immune system of the body contains
the disease and the 19th century San
Paris or la for probably
New York City as well,
it's estimated that virtually every
inhabitant had encountered microbacterium
tuberculosis,
but most remained asymptomatic
and noninfectious.
An active infection was promoted
by a compromised immune system,
let's say perhaps heredity,
alcoholism,
malnutrition,
drug abuse,
the presence of concurrent infections
that are immunosuppressive and our own
times.
One can think of malaria,
aids or two diabetes as forming a
good substratum for tuberculosis.
What are the symptoms of TB?
Well,
it's extremely variable.
One of the mysteries of medicine in fact,
is the course of tuberculosis
in the human body.
It can be fulminant and
lead to death and months.
This is often called galloping consumption
at the time or Miliary tuberculosis.
Alternatively,
there can be an onset of symptoms followed
by recovery or remission and then a
relapse and instead of
leading to early death,
it can lead to a long chronic illness,
often punctuated by prolonged remissions
and equally mysterious relapses.
Before the age of antibiotics,
some 80% of cases were deemed and fatally,
but in a time span that varied from
up to 1520 years and in every age the
respond to serious Tanea
secures or parent cures.
Let's look at two opposite extremes.
Two famous cases,
the medical careers of two famous
19th century British riders.
The first is John keys
who lived from 1795 until his death from
tuberculosis and 1821 no 1821 because
he fell ill in February,
1820 and died the next year at the age
of 26 from galloping and consumption.
Kate's in fact became an icon of the
relationship of tuberculosis to the arts
and to genius and entire century was
familiar with the fact that he contracted
the disease while tending his diet,
dying brother,
that he made a desperate departure from
Britain to Rome in search of health and
it knows the world,
knew at the time of his death and burial
there after a final period that was
widely and romantically regarded as his
most productive and brilliant his life
was described by romantic
riders as not of a meteor,
a comment or a candle that
rapidly burned itself out.
And this became a focal point.
And Keats himself did for the way
this disease was construed or socially
constructed in the middle of the 19th
century as the disease of genius,
it was considered to be a disease
of sensibility and civilization.
Let's look at the disease,
um,
of a different person whom you all know.
Well,
this is Robert Louis Stevenson
who lived from 1850 to 1,894.
This is a picture of him and about 18,
19.
Now Stevenson,
unlike kicks,
battled tuberculosis for decades,
he went in and out of
health spas and sanatoriums,
but he led a long and productive
life that was ended in fact,
ironically not by tuberculosis,
but probably by a stroke.
Now in the 19th century,
physicians regarded the course of
pulmonary disease as passing through three
stages as they saw it.
But remember though,
before the tuberculin skin test
and the development of radiology,
tuberculosis was difficult to diagnose
as the symptoms mimic those of other
common diseases.
And even if the diagnosis was accurate,
one stage merged
imperceptibly into another.
But for 19th century physicians,
there was still this distinction. Now,
the first stage as they described
it was marked by a persistent cough.
Some difficulty in breathing,
especially after exercise.
The patient would sweat profusely.
There would be an elevated pulse
pain in the chest and shoulders,
general lassitude, a
loss of weight, power,
declining performance
at work or at school.
Then came the second stage when the cough
became tormenting and frequent and the
patient would begin to
cough up a greenish phlegm.
He or she would experience intermittent
fevers spiking twice daily at copia
sweating and a rapid pulse.
The patient would suffer from severe
fatigability from hoarseness that made it
difficult and painful to eat
or to speak above a whisper.
There would be extreme
shortness of breath on exertion.
Pain in the joints of the body.
Then came the third stage
of advanced tuberculosis,
which gave the most common 19th century
name to the disease consumption.
That is a frightening emaciation in
which the body wasted away or seem to be
consumed.
The face would be hollow.
The complexion Pale.
Perhaps this was one of the reasons
that it was called the white plague.
The eyes would be sunken in their sockets
and a patient could easily look like
this.
This is a picture of a consumptive patient
in 1892 the cough now seemed like a
death rattle and the
patient would cough blood.
There would be constant
pain in the joints.
The legs would be swollen,
there would be fever,
often uncontrollable diarrhea
and extreme shortness of breath.
At that point,
the diagnosis was certain,
but at this advanced stage,
death was imminent and it's
form was unpleasant and painful.
Often asphyxia as the patient virtually
drowned on the phlegm in his or her
lungs or there could be a sudden and
unstoppable hemorrhage with blood rushing
from the mouth and nostrils and
the patient again suffocating.
Well, what was it that happened
to the lungs? Well, here's a,
some modern ex-ray slide
of a TB patient's lungs.
And let's look behind the X-ray
at a pictures of the lungs.
Here are, is a set of healthy lungs, um,
hopefully like all of yours.
And then I'd like to take you through
the drawings and pictures of the process
called cavitation in the lungs and
what the way in which the mycobacterium
tuberculosis consumes
the respiratory organs.
This is a famous drawing by Renee Lynette,
you know,
of the Paris School of medicine
who was a tuberculosis authority.
And he did this drawing of the onset
of the cavitation in the lungs.
Let's look,
uh,
at a picture of it.
Uh,
this is the process of necrosis
at work in the tissues.
And the end result would be
the destruction of the lungs,
which would look more or less like that.
Yeah.
So this was, uh, an enormously painful,
horrible and unpleasant disease.
And I want to argue that there are two
great eras in the modern history of
tuberculosis in which the disease was
conceived or thought of quite differently
and without much relationship to the
reality of the quality of the symptoms.
The two periods are divided by the
watershed of the germ theory of disease
established by Robert Kaul from about
1882 and slowly then accepted thereafter
by the medical profession and
educated society as a whole,
not instantly,
but in the decades that follow.
Now I'd like to call the first era
the era of consumption or perhaps the
romantic era of tuberculosis.
Let's define it from the end of the
18th century to the middle to the bout.
Uh,
the time of Robert caughts discovery.
It was jolted first by in the 1860s and
seventies by the work of Sean Antoine
via Ma and France,
who first convincingly proposed
the idea that TB was contagious.
And then the romantic era clearly came
to an end with the work of Robert Call
when accepts this new interpretation
and the word consumption begins to fade
from popular usage.
Thomas Men's great book,
the Magic Mountain is perhaps the
last great artistic expression of the
consumptive era and it susceptibilities.
Now,
what was the idea behind the
romantic or consumptive theory?
It's most authoritative
formulation was fine.
The great authority of the Paris
School of medicine, when they Lynette,
who's drawing you just saw the man who
invented the stethoscope and spent his
life listening to the lungs
of tuberculosis patients.
Lynette talked about what he
called the essential list theory.
Ironically,
given the opposition of the parish
school to Galen and humorless teachings,
we could see a centralism
as actually a form of humor.
Realism revived a kind of anti
contagion aneurysm in classic dress.
Now note the irony your friend ackerk
necked at is the historian of medicine
observed dryly. After all, things
have to be explained somehow.
Well,
TB was explained and primarily by internal
causes due to the inherited essence
of the patients,
his or her constitution
or in Linnex jargon,
the patients diathesis which caused
him or her to be susceptible to the
immediate factors that
triggered the actual illness.
So you're a diathesis was
an inborn inherited defect,
precipitated or immediate
causes supervened and these
were thought to be some
irregularity in the patient's life.
Very important in the literature
or alcoholism and sexual excess.
Lunette postulated that two sorts
of issues were important to him.
One more what he called Lipase on
Trieste melancholy sorrow or despair.
And again, um, sexual excess,
the loss of bodily fluids was thought
to weaken the body and lead to illness,
but both were almost an aspect
of an individual's fade,
his or her nature.
So consumption,
unlike the other great epidemic killer
of the 19th century that is cholera was
not thought to be contagious
but hereditary and therefore
its victims weren't
feared or thought to be dangerous.
And Tuberculosis was a slow killer,
not a cause of sudden
death and its symptoms.
By the canons of the day,
we're deemed to be respectable and not
thought to be disgusting or source of
unbearable torment.
And death was private unlike cholera,
not a public spectacle.
Furthermore,
tuberculosis wasn't so frightening
because it was also an [inaudible] endemic
disease and was ever present in society.
So the effects on society,
we're not at all like
those of Asiatic cholera.
We mustn't think of diseases
as interchangeable causes
of death that had the
same effects on the societies.
They afflict tuberculosis,
didn't lead to terror,
hysteria, xenophobia,
revolt,
and it's for in its first phase,
it didn't lead to stigmatization,
but it's opposite.
Patients with tuberculosis were
thought to be glamorous, sexy,
and chic.
They were blameless as it was their
heredity that was responsible and there
weren't outbursts of religiosity.
There was a recognition
of Lard that in fact,
large numbers of the social
elite fell victim to the disease.
There was no poisoning frenzy.
This disease was too slow,
too unrelated to digestion,
too,
associated with the powerful
as well as the poor.
And it was true that doctors and officials
paid their tribute to the disease,
but it did have major social effects.
And let's think about what
some of them were. Uh,
first was be the widespread
experience of patients.
This is the career of invalid ism.
Tuberculosis after diagnosis
became a lifetime career.
Okay.
The rest of one's life after receiving
diagnosis was unknown and unpredictable.
And this would affect
every possible decision,
career choices,
whether to marry and have a family,
whether to place one's
normal responsibilities on
hold and to devote life to
seeking to recover health.
And so the sufferers tended to undertake
and new an all consuming occupation,
restoring health,
and to accept what would
probably be an early death.
Let's think for example of
um,
Antoine Checkoff,
who's the men on the left.
Pictured here with Leo Tolstoy.
Now checkoff who lived from 1860 to
1904 was a sufferer from consumption.
It was forced to abandon his
own career and is actress,
wife in Moscow in the attempt to
restore his shattered health to do so,
he went to the mild climate of the Crimea.
His plays were all written in the period
of his illness and all subtly have
invalid ism as a hidden
but unmentioned theme.
The protagonists in checkoffs
plays not by chance,
seem oddly unable to act.
They seem to be waiting and waiting for
events beyond their control to unfold.
The middle classes tended to go off
to what was called taking the cure.
That is they travel in Europe.
They would go to a climate that was
thought to be favorable spas and health
resorts and southern Europe on
the French Riviera or an Italy.
Those were favorite destinations and
the list of distinguished travelers is
lengthy.
Keats and Shelley went
to Rome to buy a smaller,
went to nice the Brownings
went to Florence,
Chopin went to Mayorca.
Paul Erlick went to Egypt,
but this was also true in our own country.
In the United States.
People took see journeys to recover their
health or they traveled to the West on
the South West and here the famous
frontier thesis in American history.
As you got another meaning,
health seekers formed a substantial
current that is of the movement West and
turned into a large scale movement with
the availability of the railroad from
the 1870s Colorado Springs and Pasedena
or examples of communities that were
founded by and for tuberculosis sufferers.
Also popular were other destinations,
Florida and the Caribbean,
and the cure became a kind of industry.
It was stimulated by a flood of medical
books by rumor and anecdote by brochures
prepared by interested parties
such as the railroad companies.
There was
other exotic but more affordable
ways of seeking the cure.
One was altitude therapy in which
you'd go up high in a hot air balloon.
More commonly,
people moved out doors simply
where they lived in New York City.
At the turn of the century,
the buildings were dotted with people
who had moved to live in tents on the
roofs and porches of apartment buildings
or in their back yards if they had
them.
Let me remind you of Professor
Irving Fischer of Yale University,
who in 1907 promoted health by inventing
a tent that he claimed was perfectly
ventilated for those who took to the out
of doors life and he wanted his tent to
make outdoor living affordable
for the pure, for the poor.
He himself was a consumptive,
but he regained his health after living
out of doors and he aimed to make the
cure universally available.
If you read the New York Times,
you would see there were people who
move not only to tense but also to tree
houses that they constructed in their
yards and example being Charles Battersby
of rent them Massachusetts,
a consumptive who constructed a house
between two adjoining pine trees and moved
into it full time in the winter of 1906
who knows to what extent the travels,
if people were also means to escape the
regimens that if they stayed at home
their physicians would have
subjected them to at home.
The treatments weren't
especially enjoyable.
There was bleeding and cupping
to release the noxious agents.
There were direct
applications to the lesions,
poultices ointments,
infusions.
There was also the spray therapy that
is inhalations in which the doctors were
attempting to attack the disease at
its C as you inhaled gas mixtures,
creosote and carbolic acid had a
large vogue and these centuries.
Well, what about the effectiveness
of the travels? Well,
in some cases it's probably safe to
say that the travel were beneficial for
pulmonary tuberculosis.
It probably did help to escape the urban
smog of a place like London for Lupus
full Garris.
The disease of the skin.
Sunlight is known to be beneficial and
it was probably beneficial just to have
hope and to have the belief that you
could do something to help yourself that
probably did more good than harm.
Tuberculosis also clearly had
economic and demographic effects.
Tuberculosis was the greatest killer of
the young at the time and an inevitably
limit to the growth of population.
It limited the expansion of the
economy and caused widespread poverty.
There was a new one,
awareness and sensitivity to
this death with romanticism.
Tuberculosis,
I want to say was not
the cause of romanticism,
but it is true that romantic literature
and the arts did fit some qualities
about tuberculosis. That
is romanticism, stress,
the transiency of youth,
early death,
melancholy life as a femoral,
the importance of autumn as a symbol
no longer now assemble of the harvest,
but as a time of falling leaves,
dying flowers as death sets
in genius was part of it.
The redemptive and ennobling idea of
suffering that releases the life of the
soul as the gross material body wastes
away and there was a poetic quality that
was attributed to tuberculosis.
It was sad to release
genius and creativity.
So one sees this portrayed in
romantic works in the century.
Emily Bronte, weathering heights,
Victor Hugo lame. He said,
ah Blah.
Alexandre Dumas honoring
inertia or the romantic opera,
Verdi La Traviata or Puccini's,
Labo m.
Then I would argue the tuberculosis also,
so it had an effect and the effect the
causal chain worked in both ways and
effect and promoting romanticism and
romanticism in turn promoted a certain
understanding or social construction of
the disease itself had a major impact.
Then on literature and was portrayed often
in literature and indeed in the opera
tuberculosis also had an
effect on gender issues.
I would argue that it helped to
promote a new idea of feminine beauty,
thin,
elongated to Burke jeweler,
short pallor at the time,
white powders,
not Suntan oil is today where the fashion,
let me show you an example.
This is a famous painting of a woman
at the table by to lose little trek and
you'll note that she looks extremely
polished and it's quite thin.
Uh, but what I wanted to point out
is what she has in front of her,
uh,
which is a pot of rice powder that she
puts on her face to imitate the power of
a consumptive one.
Can see this also in the paintings
of the pre Ralphio lights,
whose favorite models were
often women with tuberculosis.
Elizabeth Siddall for example,
was a model for 10 years of and then
became the wife of Dante Rosette t and
became also a model for molay.
Jane burden became the model and also the
wife of William Morris and one can see
some of the, uh, you can
see the long gated, uh,
this is Mariana.
This is the bay ought to bear tricks.
In any case,
then consumption was a fatal,
debilitating,
and excrutiatingly painful disease.
But paradoxically then it was given
positive associations in the way it was
described at the time tuberculosis
was said to make the body beautiful,
to make a person spiritual by
wasting away the gross flesh.
And it was said to enhance
creativity and genius.
How can this be explained?
Well,
in the United States,
tuberculosis was also thought
to be the white plague,
partly because it was popularly regarded
as a disease that affected the white
race and not African Americans who were
thought to have a different affliction.
In the middle of the
19th century tellingly,
it was called the white man's plague and
the white men scourge in this country
and in Europe.
It wasn't associated in the popular
mind with the working classes.
And people remembered that aristocrats
and artistic celebrities often contracted
it. And you can see the power of
what we might call advertising,
the endless stream of novels,
poems,
operas that extolled the beauty
and sensitivity of those afflicted.
In addition, recalling what we
said about Gubernick Plagge,
tuberculosis did not evoke the fear
of Moore's rape and sudden death.
So dreaded with bubonic plague or
Asiatic cholera with consumption.
There was no danger that a person would
be caught unaware and not even have time
to write his or her will.
The disease was spiritual in part
because it worn the sufferer of death and
ample time to work out one's relationship
with God and with the community.
And there was also a simple matter
of comparison consumption. Death,
consumptive death was perhaps construed
as beautiful because pulmonary disease
didn't disfigure in
the manner of smallpox.
It's symptoms weren't degrading
in the manner of Asiatic cholera.
Well,
so to make the point,
let's turn to a work that
probably all of you know,
the most influential,
best selling novel of the 19th century,
which was Harriet Beecher
snow uncle Tom's cabin.
You probably know very well that it was
a religious novel about Social Justice
and God's way with men,
that it was about Simon legree and
the horrors of slavery and called for
abolition.
But you've probably forgotten that it
was also a major tuberculosis novel and
that the heroin at when the child
little ava dies of consumption.
Let me remind you of how Harriet Beecher
Stowe described approaching death and
she wrote for so bright and placid was
the farewell voyage of the little spirit
by such sweet and fragrant breezes was
the small bark born towards the heavenly
shores that it was impossible to
realize that death was approaching.
The child felt no pain,
only a trend,
cool soft weakness daily and
almost insensibly increasing.
And she was so beautiful,
so loving, so trustful,
so happy.
The one could not resist the soothing
influence of that air of innocence in
peace that seem to breathe all around her.
Her father found a strange,
calm coming over him.
It wasn't hope that was impossible.
It was not resignation.
It was only a calm resting in the present.
That seems so beautiful that he wished
to think of no future was like that hush
of spirit that we feel the mid,
the bright mild woods of
autumn when the bright,
hectic flushes on the trees and the last
lingering flowers by the brook and we
joy in all the more because we
know that it will soon pass away.
I would argue that this barest little
relationship to the actual extraordinary
suffering of tuberculosis at the very end,
and I think it makes a good way to have
a transition from the consumptive era to
what I would call the era of tuberculosis,
when the way that disease,
this disease was constructed and
understood changes radically.
And this comes about after the germ
theory of disease and the work of Robert
Call when the disease was found not to
be hereditary and due to one's diaphysis,
but to be a nasty,
contagious disease.
When softwares became objects of
fear and stigma attached to them,
when the glamor of
consumption was stripped away,
as was its association with feminine
beauty and Mail Genius and poetry and its
appeal as a period of spirituality
and sexuality disappeared.
So that's what I want
to talk about next time,
which is the movement from the era of
consumption to the era of tuberculosis.